what's up everyone
uh welcome to culture binge the
wisecrack
podcast where we get all exploratory
in the cultural zeitgeist uh i am
michael joined as always by the
dark lord of depressing thursday is alec
and the celebratory sage of sunny
saturdays
serbia how are you all doing today that
was your best intro
in a while uh i'm great doing very well
how are you
good i'm excited to be here i'm excited
for the second episode in a row
to be live again that's really good i'm
glad they let us back on after youtube
shut us down for shocking content just
so everyone knows that's a joke
um and just to remind everyone as well
we are live
every other wednesday and then the
podcast goes up for you to download it
on fridays so making that clear for
everyone
there's a little bit of a gap and
sometimes people have wondered why do we
take it down from youtube well you got
to be here for the special edition and
then you can download it on friday just
so everyone knows that but also
uh we archive all of these episodes on
wisecast
just search wisecast you'll find it it's
basically the same logo but it's a
little
pink and purpley wise cass
so i have to practice my plurals a lot
for here's a little inside baseball for
everyone we make videos at wisecrack
often evan has to stop me and make me
redo
words that are plural s's because i
often swallow them
yeah i've left those notes a few times
well there you go no one's perfect
but we are excited to be here today we
have a lot to talk about we're going to
talk about
um the i guess surprising resurgence of
rebecca black
we are going to talk about covid vaccine
sneaks
sorry that my voice got heated when i
brought that up and we're going to talk
about
um tech cities which is
not cool but might sound fun but to get
started we're gonna do
slaps and chaps uh we'll see if alec
participates in traps this time around
he's often
you know wanting to keep it positive
which i respect so let's start with
serbia
serbia what do you got for slaps and
chaps this go round
so uh patrick dexter slaps
uh patrick dexter is a guy who spent
lockdown
posting wonderful videos on youtube of
himself
playing the cello in open-air recitals
he sits behind this
really charming cottage next to a lake
and he plays everything from beethoven
to
like a 12th century irish christmas
carol
and the videos are so relaxing i highly
recommend that you check them out his
channel is
patrick dexter cello and he's also on
patreon
um what chaps i watched bling empire
on netflix and
it's so for those of you who don't know
it's like a reality show
um like a real life version of crazy
rich asians the movie
and after watching it everything chaps
now i want
things to just be super rich
aren't they arms dealers someone told me
that one of them was an army's deal
anna is her fortune comes from arms
dealing
oh her parent her dad or somebody but
that's where she got her fortune from
yeah yeah she didn't sell the guns she
just got the like royalty checks from
like the dead babies that's how that
works right
she's very generous she like gives
diamonds to people and stuff
and she just here's a blog that was
taken from the corpse of like a dead
afghani child
well then i'm not indoors i like the
show too though um
my favorite is the male model guy who's
the one oh yeah quote-unquote poor one
yeah who's like the audience's avatar
and he has
a zoolander-esque vibe and then he's
very handsome but like
in the sweetest way possible very dumb
yes very dumb
but very simple charmingly dumb like a
puppy
kind of yes big fan of that guy a fun
show makes made me feel bad about myself
though um for maybe different reasons
that's fun um and i like that your chap
was still kind of positive it was like
this thing was so good now nothing else
feels good afterwards
yeah so there you go um alec how about
you slap some chaps
uh my slaps uh is is really lame this
week i
meant to watch all of it but i watched
the first 30 minutes of jewish and the
black messiah and so far the first 30
minutes is what slaps it it's good i
hope the rest of the movie
is good who knows maybe the second act
is going to be awful
but check it out uh lucky stanfield
love that guy daniel kullua also awesome
uh as far as chaps uh
one of my favorite podcasts may or may
not be canceled and that's all i'll say
oh yeah that's i won't say anything else
but yeah that's i've been thinking about
this one a lot
um if you know you know if you know
shout it out in the chat
um i i will say this too to i don't want
to uh steal
alex slap but um as someone who who
completed
judas and the black messiah um very good
movie
so i'll say that just a very good movie
um even though i'm bitter at my partner
because she fell asleep part of the way
through it and i was like
really really you're gonna sleep through
this but that's a different thing for
another day um my slap will be
um a novel that i got halfway through
this weekend
a new one from a writer called lauren
oiler a book called fake accounts um
it's just very good and it's a novel
that deals with
questions of like our identity on the
internet the way the digital culture
can make us sometimes feel a little bit
alienated there's some fun social and
political analysis there
and it's very funny so if you're looking
for a new book to read that's a fun one
um my chap would be
that the bachelor's falling apart guys
uh the the bachelor franchise isn't a
weird
thing uh they've had a racism
controversy this past week the people
that run the show have responded
very weirdly and it's made the show feel
kind of icky to watch
now some of you might be saying really
michael just now you feel icky about the
bachelor
you know there's only much so much
self-delusion um
that one can have so that's been kind of
a bummer much like alex favorite
podcast well the difference is this is a
good podcast that does good things
whereas and no hatred to anyone
who yeah like i watched plenty of trash
but you know when a when a trash thing
goes downhill i feel like we should feel
less sad about it
yes so that's that um and just a quick
shout out as well
to our honorary slapper and chopper
dudabiz 1985. thank you so much for in
the chat thank you so much for donations
um one slaps for him is rediscovering
sea shanties on tick tock which is very
fun
chaps snowstorms in michigan and uh yeah
genuine uh
shouts and and hugs to everyone across
the country who's very cold right now
yeah around the world all i gotta say
about that yeah
um we very much feel for you um okay so
before we get into our first topic quick
reminder everyone
subscribe rate and review um subscribe
to this podcast whatever platform you
like to do it on rate it preferably five
stars
if you don't want to do five stars just
don't rate it at all you know what i
mean i'm going to be honest with you
well except for
alec will accept four i will not so you
make of that what you will
um and then in the reviews you know
tell us anything i don't know so have
fun with the reviews we've said before
tell us you know what cocktail we would
be who should play us in a movie
recently someone wrote in and said
what band we would all be sadly all i
remember about this
is that i got to be the bestie boys
which i thought was fun and alec was
mumford and sons which i
thought was endlessly delightful serbie
do you remember who you were i was
so it was this woman i hadn't heard of
yours i've never heard her i think she's
this beautiful eastern european
uh singer and i actually listened to
some of her songs and i was like oh this
is amazing
yeah so we like it so if you review us
just pick a category
um the food us presidents european
nations
musical artists famous fascists and
totalitarian leaders and tell us which
one we we match up with
um so do that we'd love it and we love
you so thanks so let's get into it our
first topic this week um alex is going
to talk to us
about rebecca black someone who i we
might remember
from her i think the music video her
parents got her for her birthday when
she was in high school for a song called
friday
it was a viral sensation then led to
some backlash in her life
now she's back i guess yeah she's been
around
and so for anyone who doesn't know and
god dammit i can't believe this is 10
years ago
but in 2011 the world was a different
place
rebecca black was 13 years old uh
her mom uh paid four thousand dollars
to a record label called ark music
um to have like a song produced and a
music video produced
and that was the song friday as you may
or may not know
friday friday got to get down with
friday everyone's looking forward to the
weekend
partying pardon yeah i don't want to hum
it i was told we could get demonetized
for that
but um it was
a kind of a weird time in the internet
ever it became super super viral
because of how shitty of a song it was
uh like in the vein of william hung
getting super famous
uh kind of a few years earlier uh
people were very very mean to her
because the song was very bad and i just
remember a lot of the discourse was like
look at this like rich kid getting
spoiled and her mom doing it
at the same time now as an adult i'm
like oh my god this is a 13 year old
child
and sure you know she comes from maybe a
more privileged background but like what
the
was wrong with the entire internet
basically like bringing up the
sacrificial lamb to make fun of
uh she's talked in interviews about it
being kind of traumatic one of those
interviews
i think is called terrible thanks for
asking i haven't listened to it but uh
it was summarized to me by someone who
has
but she just talks about being a dumb
kid and having like the whole
kind of world thrust upon her her
friends at first were super excited to
be in the video and become famous but
then turned on her when they realized
that they were collective
joke um she in the usa today interview
talks about the bullying and depression
like the career setbacks uh but weirdly
enough and this is what i find kind of
strange
she just like kept going with the music
career
she put out a song not too long ago
called girlfriend i listened to it i'm
not like a huge pop music guy but i
would say
it's fine it's not you know uh
horrendously bad like friday but the
reason i'm talking about this is 10-year
anniversary and she put out a remix
uh we have some again we can't we can't
play it but we have some images
of that music video uh and it's weird
that she's kind of just like
fully identified with this thing that
sort of ruined her life
and now is also capitalizing off it
because again like
you know i don't know how successful she
is as a pop singer but i think
she would have even less success had it
not been for
this horrific meme she became uh
i also think it's interesting like six
months earlier there was
another similar case of just like a
child becoming famous on the internet
for being stupid
um the person at the time known as
jessie slaughter now they go by
damien slaughter uh or or just damien
i'm not sure
i think the last name is fake but um
damien
uh if anyone remembers the done goofed
meme basically this kid started beef
with 4chan
and got like doxxed and harassed all of
this stuff and then uh their dad put out
like this really like angry like
you done goofed we're gonna backtrace
you and call a cyber police and to be
honest like
her dad freaking the out was really
funny but
um yeah it seemed like in 2010 2011 we
were really
into like making children famous for the
all the wrong reasons
that's what i want to talk about also in
context of you know i just watched that
britney spears documentary
yeah i'm all i'm out on kids being
famous because there was you know the
britney spears documentary huge bummer
um there was a documentary that hbo put
out earlier this year or sorry last year
that was on child celebrities and child
actors and like how their lives go
that was very depressing and kind of
dark
i don't think i just don't think kids
should be famous like for all the
examples
of a famous kid who turns out pretty
decent
like beyonce let's say who is on star
search and stuff like that
we have like a hundred examples of
famous kids thrust into the spotlight
whose lives go bad
it was already enough in like when i was
in middle school if you knew someone
said a bad thing about you or someone
wrote on the bathroom that like
this was your mom's number and she
wanted to go out with other middle
school boys or something
to have all of this on the internet it's
just a lot i find it scary maybe i sound
like an old man right here
i just say like keep keep kids anonymous
that felt weird to say but you know what
i mean
i agree i think that children don't they
haven't developed those coping
mechanisms yet they don't have
they haven't developed resilience or
anything they have no
baseline to understand what's good and
what's bad
in terms of what people are saying about
you everything feels horrible
at that age and it can have such
long-term
lasting effects if somebody says
something terrible about you when you're
like six years old
i mean you could be like 35 and like
still dealing with those issues
um but going back to rebecca black i
think it's incredible
that she's stuck with music this whole
time and that she
reclaimed that song that caused her so
much trauma
when she was 13. i am very interested in
how she developed
so much resilience because i don't know
that i could handle that i feel like i
would have given up on music i would be
like this isn't for me
the whole world hates me yeah i don't
know i feel like there's a perverse
incentive again with the william hung
thing it's like
you know your goal as a dumb 13 year old
is to become famous
obviously and it's like oh you can get
on good morning america
and like sure the host might be nice to
you but like you're on there because
people
are laughing at you it's basically the
plot of the joker now that i'm thinking
about it
um but yeah like
you know again rebecca black and william
hung like they got all these
opportunities like to perform or to to
be voice actors or
in things and to be on talk shows and
all these things and you know even if
you know katie kirk wasn't laughing in
their face like they were on there
because people were
were laughing at them and so like
you know at the same time like what
you're saying serbia is that like she
kept going
in spite of this by the same time like
the system
was like kind of tricking her into
keeping going by like the sort of
threading along the uh the the promise
of fame but not every person
who is mocked does that though like some
people just like fade
fade away or feel like they can't deal
with it so i do agree with you like
there is a sort of like
hamster wheel where you're like oh i'm
getting laughed at but i'm also getting
more press and more money
but i do think that there is something
incredible about somebody who's
dealt with global uh
mocking like like a worldwide
session of people mocking your interests
and then you just keep going with it
yeah yeah i mean it does i don't want to
be too reduct
productive here it doesn't hurt when
your mockery comes with
a a big earning potential i know most
people i know that got viciously bullied
did not have a
a earning potential and like pr
campaigns attached to it
so i feel like less bad for someone who
gets really bullied but can at least
make a bunch of money off of it
i know it sounds shitty but like i don't
know it's it's that's real
um this does make me think as well the
whole rebecca black thing about
like the claudia conway on america oh my
god the whole thing
um just a quick tl dr type thing
claudia conway daughter of george conway
and kellyanne conway who's getting
famous on tick tock for being like whoa
my parents suck
um was on the season premiere of
american idol some would argue
i would argue um that she's not a super
talented singer which is fine because
she's 16 and has tons of time to develop
and whatever she wants to develop into
but they kept her on the show in the
general sense was we're kind of putting
this young woman
through the ringer um and like letting
her stay famous because of the fact that
her parents are like
right-wing political folks it's just it
felt icky and it reminds me of this a
little bit and the things that we do to
like
viral children yeah and the whole thing
there
too was like she was on tick-tock i
think accusing her mom of being
emotionally maybe physically abusive
yeah physically too yeah
and you know obviously
take those things seriously like get the
authorities involved but i just
even see like kind of journalists i
respect you know
i i think people's instinct is like oh
let's publicize the out of this to
like get people involved and i feel like
no this is like a kid like the thing is
to like
call your friend who works at child
services to like investigate this
quietly and without
because like you just don't you don't
know you know i'm pretty sure
that lionel richie is a certified social
worker
and he is now on the case and then katy
perry has a background
in child trauma and psychology and then
um the other guy
luke bryan brian uh he's just he's just
a good time country boy
sorry for that digression oh you were
this is oh those are the judges
richie and katy perry do not have
backgrounds they're both very talented
and seem like nice people
i i like them very much and i i think
they seem like great hosts but no
they're not that um
so does it seem then like so so rebecca
black remixed her song had a bunch of
pretty heavy hitters on the remix right
now like
sorry one more time i was reading a
comment that struck me
wow um so rebecca black who we're
talking about
um so she she you know remixed her own
song has some heavy hitters on it
it seems like now you know is she
transcended to where
people just think this is cool in a
non-ironic way you know what i mean like
so
i guess that's what i wonder and sort of
i don't get too mad and this isn't
really meta
but you know do we think now people are
rocking with this song because it's like
funny that it's rebecca black
or are people like oh she seems kind of
cool now she has this
cool cyberpunk vibe in the video and she
has some great people on it like do we
think
this is indicative of her you know kind
of being taken
seriously as an artist no
um i i think that the friday remix is
intentionally like
bad like this on girlfriend again if you
listen to it it's just like a normal pop
song
like it's not auto tuned to or
anything whereas friday
the remix it's like tuned up a ton it's
basically kind of like a mockery of
itself but
i do i feel like there's a pushing past
the like ironic liking of a thing to
just like
this reminds me of when i was a teen
being stupid like i feel like there's a
genuine sort of like uh emotional like
warmness people might feel in relation
to rebecca black now like
for me i was i think like 20 or
something but like if you're a 15 year
old girl
and like she's being made fun of on the
internet i could see how you're like oh
like i'm rooting for them you know
i liked the song like the original i
didn't think it was bad i used to sing
it it was fun wow
i thought it was nice i was like oh this
is such a sweet
song that you would probably sing like
on your way home from school i thought
it was really cute and i
was i was excited that she was doing it
i didn't think it was anything weird
i guess i i was the minority there i
didn't mind it
yeah i i think she just lucked out i not
lucked out i think
didn't luck out because i don't know
like even when i was in high school
i knew people that made like music
videos and recorded songs but it was
just rudimentary and it was
just slightly pre-youtube so it's like
she just
caught that wave perfectly what about
fred durst you went to high school with
like fred durst and all the other like
uh swamp rock people right yeah yeah oh
yeah i'm 55 years old
and went to high school in jacksonville
florida with leonard skinnard
members of limp biscuit tom petty the
guys from creed
uh those were my buds yeah
um pretty embarrassing oh it's so weird
that florida's whole pot mo
florida had swamp rat metal and then
they had like teen pop it was a weird
world
we're not talking about florida now um
so what do we think what what what's the
future of rebecca black do we think she
sticks around as a a viable pop artist
is this her her second 15 minutes of
fame
i hope i haven't listened enough to her
catalog to really like judge
the artistic merit uh but i hope it's
like a
hannah montana becoming miley cyrus i
mean i know miley cyrus is miley cyrus
but it's like oh look at this like dumb
disney star it's like oh actually this
person is really talented
uh i would love to see that sort of arc
for
rebecca black that sounds great like
that too serbia any final thoughts on
rebecca black
i'm rooting for her go rebecca black
yeah and you know
why not yeah why not there is one person
in the comments wants to know why we're
talking it's the 10th anniversary of
friday and so if that feels like
it happened last year time is awful
an awful awful illusion it's cruel and
it hurts us all
for some of us friday means the classic
chris tucker
and ice cube film that came out 25 years
ago
so that says a lot about a person you
say do you like friday and if they
that one might think of the rebecca
black song one might think of the ice
cube movie
i think one of those things is better in
the chat let us know are you more of a
friday than movie or friday the song
person
um oh yeah that's great good to talk
about that before we move on i want to
share something with everyone that i'm
truly excited about and this isn't some
like
bullshitty me shielding for any one
thing um wisecrack
is a part of a new social media platform
i don't
use the right term i know that sounds
good the future um but it's this thing
called hi-ho
okay now hi-ho is this app and when i
first heard about it i was like i don't
know but then i got on and i was like i
really like this
here's the deal hi-ho allows you to have
real-time video conversations
um with a bunch of different people you
can post questions messages things
people can reply to and have these sort
of threaded conversations
it's like twitter if there was video and
conversation and as of right now less
trolls and psychopaths
and wisecrack um is one of the first
channel platform brands that's going to
be on there we actually just launched
our channel
today and you can jump on there and what
this really means is and i know on this
podcast
our favorite part of it is the calls and
the emails and interacting with you on
the chat and having you hit us up on
social media
and this just creates a space just for
that so
here's the deal if you went on the app
store right now and put in hi-ho the app
store would be like what
because it's not live it's not public
but we're going to get you on the beta
version
to get involved right now so all you
have to do is you go to hi-ho so
h-i-h-o dot video slash
beta or beta b-e-t-a wisecrack once
again that's
hi-ho dot video slash beta slash
wisecrack there is a
link in the description if you're
watching right now um download the app
it's going to make you like
download this other you'll figure it out
you're all smarter than me so you can do
it
jump on and right off the bat you'll see
we have some posts up there
reply to them discuss i'm going to talk
back with you
we're going to have a fun time um and
then we're gonna see
what happens we might try out some new
formats on that we might use some of
your comments
to create some fun content it's just a
way for you to get more
involved with the channel and for us to
get more involved with you
uh on hiaho come chat with us on hi-ho
yeah i i uh installed the app
and i immediately went on and asked
burns who does he think he is
and what gives him the right and i think
just just
more of that if you want you could also
ask questions like
what's your favorite philosopher what do
you think about kierkegaard's concept of
anxiety
or uh you could just troll him not like
a bad troll like no
weird death threats but just like nice
trolling what's invent nice trolling
okay but for right now go on
first things that are up there we have
some initial conversations going one is
just an intro to the channel
one um i asked people what class changed
their life
i know school sucks but like there's
always one good class um
and then i uh there's a prompt there
about what movie changed the way you see
the world so go in download it um record
yourself
do the damn thing it's gonna be really
fun hi ho dot video slash beta
wisecrack and you're the first ones on
there i think it's so exciting and you
can like
i don't know you could talk to tim
ferriss or something um so that's i hope
now we want to talk about something that
isn't cool because hyo is cool this
thing isn't cool
um i don't know about you all when i was
in school
and this is a real thing i i would get
in trouble
for freaking out if someone like cut a
line
or cheated and i remember once this kid
jumped ahead in like the lunch line with
his friends and i like lost my
um because i just had a deep feeling
that injustice is bad in all places
that's just who i am um and serbie
is going to tell us about some line
cutting that's happening that's a little
worse than cutting in line on cookie day
at the school cafeteria
yes debatable but yeah so a few days ago
we received an email from jake who
talked about a canadian couple
jumping the vaccine cue here's what he
had to say
since you all seem to enjoy on
the moralist self-centered scum of
society
i thought i'd pass along the story of a
couple who are possibly the most hated
people in canada at the moment
the gift of the story is a
multi-millionaire ceo and his trophy
wife traveled to a remote northern
community from british columbia
to pose as motel workers and receive
vaccinations that are earmarked for the
vulnerable indigenous population
of beaver creek yukon the two have since
been charged and the man fired from his
job
but canadians are still feeling pretty
pissed about this
it's probably as classic an example of
rich elites thinking they can do
whatever they want with no consequences
as i've seen during the pandemic the
monetary fines are basically nothing to
them
so it feels good that they're at least
getting absolutely dragged online over
this
they literally stole vaccines from
indigenous people who have already had
virtually everything stolen
from them by white ding-dongs like this
guy and his wife
so i had been thinking about this
because i've heard other examples
of people doing shady things in order to
get the vaccine
sooner and this is the most extreme
story i've heard
but other ones that i've heard people
driving 13 and a half hours
across states to volunteer at a
vaccination mega site in
for a few hours just to get the vaccine
other people trying to get temporary
jobs
at grocery stores so that they're in a
higher tier
um in terms of vaccine distribution and
other people lying about being
caregivers to the elderly
so like if there's like grandparents or
somebody living separately
the the other family will like take them
to the vaccine site and be like oh will
we take care of them so can we get the
vaccine as well
um and so this makes me so mad i
i know that we want to get everybody
vaccinated but
i just i hate the dishonesty i think
it's a different story if you're
at a pharmacy or if you're somewhere and
they announce on the intercom system
like hey we have three vaccines they're
about to
expire does anybody want them um which
i've heard happens as well
but this just is so morally
reprehensible and it makes me so bad
and the sad fact is that the people who
can afford to do these things like
fly and drive across uh states or to go
to various places to take
um low-paying jobs like at a grocery
store or at a motel
these are the same people that haven't
have had an easier time staying
safe in the pandemic um their careers
have
easily pivoted to remote working they
can
order their groceries online they can
set up home offices they have
easy access to the internet for work and
school and
it's disturbing to me that the
population that can stay safest during a
pandemic is doing
just about anything in order to get
vaccinated
i'm so heated anyway how do you two feel
about this
have you heard stories i have so many
thoughts uh
because on one end like i i feel that
rage and especially with this canadian
couple they're the worst
um i think there's like a lot of less
severe cases of just like people
you see getting the vaccine you're like
oh did you really need it um
and so like on one end i'm hearing
stories
about uh well for instance i
i know a person who works at a hospital
who is eligible because they work at the
hospital but they work remotely and for
a while they're like
you know what i'm not going to get this
like other people need it more but then
found out that like
nobody thought like 40 of people at the
hospital were getting it and like doses
weren't gonna go bad
and so finally they're like i'm gonna
get it um i know people
who you know in some states uh if your
bmi is over a certain point you can get
a vaccine and i know
some people who like have an old
doctor's report from like four years ago
and they've since lost a ton of weight
and so like there's that and you know
maybe there's still lingering effects of
you're still at risk or something like
that um
and then like so i just see a lot of
people and i feel like i shouldn't get
in the place where it's like oh
like do you really like deserve it i
feel like you know i like the line
metaphor it's kind of like uh when you
go up to a place and there is no line
form because our country's a show
uh and sort of you stand back waiting
for a line to form but instead people
are just bum rushing and you're like
this is a problem but also the people
like bum rushing it like aren't
necessarily the problem the problem is
that there's like
not like an actual line and like a great
example like
every state is so different and shitty
and up that
there's also lots of cases where i don't
fault people for sort of
circumventing the system for instance
there is a person in my family with
leukemia in massachusetts
you would think like very high risk
massachusetts i think currently or until
recently was only 75 years or older and
now they're doing
you know expanding that too like if you
have two comorbidities so it's not just
like oh you have leukemia it's like you
have leukemia and a high bmi or you have
leukemia
and like a history of heart disease or
something like that and so basically
this person is like oh like i should
start smoking so that i can get
this vaccine
and like you know this person could
travel across state lines which is like
a little shady but the end of the day
i'm not gonna be like oh you
person you know compromise with cancer
i'm not gonna
get mad at them but i think there's like
a lot of cases like that like people's
grandparents who are
you know either 65 or 64 like who are at
risk and might be
like cutting the line in small ways like
i don't think we should
not that you're doing this serbia i
don't think we should go around scolding
them at the same time
that canadian couple yeah there's
also a piece i think it was in like
either new york magazine or hollywood
reporter um shouts to both publications
they had a thing yesterday about people
in the film industry who are getting
vaccines and a big thing that's
happening now i guess
is private planes full of executives are
flying to florida
to get vaccines there so crews from la
and new york are doing that
um there was a few doctors in it who
anonymously said there's like
celebrities who are asking for vaccines
but want to keep it secret because they
know how bad of a look it'll be
yeah and i guess there's even some pr
people who are like telling their
clients to not do it
because of public backlash like if we
find out that jennifer lawrence got
vaccinated before us we'll all be like
you jennifer lawrence
yeah um how could we though she's
america's sweetheart but
um yeah no i think this sucks i do think
to i guess roof off what you just said
alec like
i have some sympathy for the fact that
people are treating this like the
hunger games because
it has felt like that the response from
the top and from state and local
uh and federal governments has felt a
little hunger games-ish like it's every
person for themselves
so it's not shocking that people have
resorted to that logic
yeah um but it's also a bummer because
the sort of like communal logic of being
like to be corny like all in this
together
only works if we're all in this together
it kind of falls apart when people start
cutting lines
but that said i guess the one thing that
i think with all of this and the
canadian example is just such
utter and i hate those people and
would physically fight them i will text
them my address if they want it they can
come find me
um but for a lot of people who are
getting them
in less insidious ways it's like i guess
at least it gets us a little closer to a
hurting immunity and it's better for
everyone if more people are vaccinated
um something that's happening here in
l.a that i find kind of annoying is
people
are camping out near vaccination sites
to try to get extra doses
and a reporter two days ago was at a
site in south los angeles and south la's
largely like a brown and black community
and most of the people camped out were
like
white college students which like that
annoyed me a little bit
not a little bit a lot bit um that those
are the people camping out trying to get
those and it's also annoying that like
a healthy 21 year old does not need it
that bad
but they're gonna spread it to people
who are gonna that that's the other
thing like the shittiest most selfish
people who are gonna cut the line are
the ones that are like
indoor dining eight times a week and
like should be vaccinated so they don't
oh yeah
that's a up thing the the people
who are the worst i guess
there'd be the highest benefit of
vaccinating them but those of us yeah
i'll say us who have done a really good
job this whole time are going to be the
last people to get the vaccination
like i i i know myself like i am not
going to get it
until i am able to whatever system in my
city allows me to do it get one they're
saying late july i think there's there's
no what's happening to august or
september but um
it just it's a bummer but you know i
guess
it's like it's like i think green day
said this once nice guys finish last
yeah sorry about that i i didn't mean to
quote green day i feel really bad about
it
um i think the other thing though is
like with the lines of people and stuff
i i even thought about and i don't so
new york recently andrew cuomo uh
i was gonna say like invert bless his
heart like but i don't know curse his
heart i don't know he's the worst uh
but anyway he said that you can stop
wasting doses uh my
i know pharmacists literally just we
can't give the doses unless you're in
the actual category so we're just
throwing doses away every single
day
now now you can and so the question is
oh is there going to be sort of these
standby lines
and should i as a person who can go like
go go get it
and like i think it sucks in the sense
that i'm
a person who's like lucky enough to have
a job where like i could take half a day
off
to like walk over to a hospital and do
it and like other people
aren't and like that is shitty and these
lines of people like there's a
shittiness to it but at the same time
it's like
we gotta vaccinate people thanks duane
hatmill for the donation by the way
thank you thank you so much so i think
it's different in that situation like if
you
just can get the vaccine because there's
it's going to expire
or if you have a compromised immune
system and you are going to do something
shady so that you get the vaccine
i think that's fine my issue is people
who
are already quite privileged who are the
ones that the whole pandemic like the
pandemic has not affected them at all
they were still
dining they were still traveling they're
the ones that every single person that
i've heard who has been something shitty
has been one of those people who's just
been like the vaccine's not a big deal
and it bothers me that well if it's not
such a big deal then why are you going
to such great lengths to get the vaccine
now
but it's that logic too i think it's the
same type of person that like
always needs to have the best or coolest
thing i think these are the same people
that make sure they get like the newest
iphone and they have to have like
the newest car when it comes out and the
coolest and it's just a part of
that
like like what's the word i'm looking
for that kind of like
stunting kind of like wannabe influencer
lifestyle thing where people
they're looking for a wire cutter
article about like is the modern
moderna or fizer better like oh yeah
this one's 86 but this one's 85
effective you know as of right now i'm
team modern i think modern is more like
you know more like the arcade fire of
vaccines whereas there's like the foo
fighters
and then johnson and johnson is going to
be like the like
early strokes i was gonna say dean's jet
like they came in the game late and
they're trying to do
a thing that someone did 20 years ago
yeah
if you're in the chat let us know which
vaccine you want i want madonna because
dolly parton is behind it
so anything dolly does shouts to dolly
parton we stand here uh elsa acceptor
super bowl commercial we don't stand her
super bowl commercial oh i don't know
about that
legends are allowed to fall had make
failures two legends really up
the super bowl this should have been my
chaps
bruce springsteen made this horrible
commercial for jeep
um and bruce springsteen's a legend
don't put dirt on his name dolly pardon
also a legend
did a commercial for like door dash or
something
no not doordash it was the she did a
song called from nine to five
sorry from five to nine about how you
have to work 24
7 in our hustle culture and get like
side gigs
on apps and stuff but in a good way like
she was celebrating it after she made a
movie after she made a song for a movie
about how your boss is the worst
yeah she was celebrating the in the
current economic conditions of this
country you have to work 24 hours a day
if you want to pay rent and not die
yeah there was a there was a lot of
weird i'll say this
super bowl commercials this year a lot
of things where artists who in their
own lives have like pretty good ethics
and values
did ads for some particularly insidious
companies
i will leave it at that also look up the
sesame street ad it was a bummer
but back back to line jumping um so the
real question is
serbia you're in a walmart doing your
shopping
okay as you as you do um you hear a
thing come over the intercom that says
we have two
doses of moderna supported by dolly
parton
for whoever can get to the pharmacy
right now you're running and you see
that you're about to be the second
person
you look to your left you see an elderly
person moving slow their hip is bad
but you know you can make it do you get
the vaccine or do you let that person
get it oh 100
i would knock that down to get it
what the
i'm kidding you're a monster i'm kidding
i'm kidding
i would run i'm kidding when we when we
do this one and then
you give him a 10 tip like thank you for
your time
i don't value your labor no no what i
would do is i would run
i would get i would be like like take
the spot for the vaccine but i would
give it to the elderly person coming
i've done like that before where
like i will see that there is somebody
who's trying to get
something and i'm just closer so i'll be
like oh i'll like hold your spot for you
so that's what i would do well if any of
our listeners are elderly and have been
knocked over by serbia please send us a
line
yeah we will we'll take her out for you
that's unacceptable
um well that's exciting and you know if
you are a a vaccine sneak
send us an anonymous email we won't
snitch yeah
yeah you're a snitch ass talk to us
i think about your reason yeah i want to
know the psychology of a creep yeah
i i yeah i think there's so many like
morally excusable
examples and like a lot of gray areas
and then the morally inexcusable
examples and so i just want to explore
them all
yeah okay cool so we're gonna move on
now um
now guys i don't know if you are ever
like this thing that always happens to
me where i will be
like on an app or using a technology and
i think to myself like
i don't want to be on facebook like i
want to live
in facebook i don't want to drive a
tesla
i want to live inside of tesla i don't
want to trade bitcoin i want to live
inside of a community
founded fundamentally around the united
government of bitcoin
um and i thought this would be a dream
but now it's becoming a reality
because what i want to talk about today
is a legislature that's been
proposed in nevada that would let tech
companies form
their own governments um to be clear
form their own governments and this is
something i've thought about for a while
because when i was in
graduate school we used to do this thing
where grad students like once a month
you'd have to give like a paper or a
presentation on something that like
wasn't your main research
kind of like another thing you were
interested in and dude i went to grad
school with named reid i won't say his
last name but shout to reid great guy
he gave this presentation on how in the
future um
we were all gonna live in like
militarized zones owned by corporations
and governments would cease to exist and
it would be like
microsoft would have their compound and
like militarization on the outside and
outside the walls
of the corporate cities would just be
like poverty and terror
and everyone that day was like wow this
is a bad hang um
and we're kind of bummed when we went to
the bar afterwards but yeah
that's kind of becoming true so
and i'm reading this is from an article
there's a bunch of different people
wrote about this i'm just looking at the
gizmodo article because their
their user interface is the cleanest so
it felt easiest to read
but steve sizolak the democratic
governor of nevada
wants to incentivize incentivize
technology companies to move to his
state and this isn't just tax breaks so
often what will happen is if a state
wants to get tech companies there
they'll say come here you don't have to
pay taxes like i think tesla is moving
to texas
for that reason um but this law
would basically create this thing called
innovation zones
and that if companies could meet minimum
capital requirements so they'd have to
have at least 250 million in the bank
and plan to invest at least one billion
in the next decade
they will be able to not just have tax
breaks but to
create their own laws regulations they
could set up local governments complete
with three member boards of supervisors
any local ordinances adopted by that
board would supersede
the rules of the county in which their
innovation zone was placed
so the company yeah so the company would
have
more power in the county um
only eight types of companies are
allowed to do this though so if you're
out there thinking like
oh i'm in um you have to either work in
blockchain autonomous technology
internet of things robotics artificial
intelligence wireless technology
biometrics or renewable resource
technology
um most of those things are the exact
companies i wouldn't like listen if it
was like
like hey this sock company you make
really good socks
darn tough highly recommend them you get
to run your small town in vermont i'd be
like
i don't trust it but all right but
you're gonna make people
writing ai yeah and not only do they
have
they basically set up their own board of
supervisors with laws that supersede the
county
they also get to create a judicial court
um and they're allowed to have their own
district attorney
county clerk and sheriff
why um yes so you might be asking well
what can't they do
um they can't create a sales tax
and they can't leverage property taxes
so they can't create
new taxes um they would though be able
to tax
fuel after a certain point of time
and just to say this to them if anyone
you know just just to be clear
this is a democratic governor that's
coming up with this too in case anyone
wants to say this is some weird like
right wing thing democratic governor
um who's come up this plan i i'll
quickly say my take
um it really terrifies me i think i
think this idea sets a really
insane precedent and i think we've
already seen um with like the passing of
proposition 22 in california which is
now
um being turned into a proposition in
new york look this up if you need to i
think we've talked about it before
that we're we're sliding into a
dangerous dangerous territory
where companies and particularly tech
companies and platform services are not
only now
writing legislation they're going to be
able to have their own cities their own
courts their own
sheriffs and i don't see
how this ends well and it seems to be
fundamentally non-democratic as well
because one of the issues with the
nevada thing
is the three-person board of supervisors
in the tech city
would have more power than
democratically elected officials within
that county
so if you were a resident in whatever
county
you would have this company would have
the ability
to you know take away or replace laws
that were democratically established in
your county
by their own legislation and their own
judges and their own sheriffs
i don't like it i don't think it's
new like i don't think it's as severe
but
uh they're called like free trade zones
like i think they exist in jamaica for
instance
where uh multinational corporations
convince the jamaican government
like hey give us this area where normal
like labor laws don't apply
and so it's not again like full
government situation but they basically
get to
carve out their own like autonomous zone
where they get to do certain things
and you know they're uh nightmares and
um lots of people in the comments are
pointing out this is just a company town
which has been uh not cool recently
except disney is constantly trying to do
it again and again with places like
celebration florida uh we have a whole
video about it go check it out
but uh for anyone who doesn't know
especially in the
1800s company towns were like a factory
would come in they'd build a school a
church
a grocery store they would pay you in
script which wasn't real money uh
it was like v bucks that you could go to
your store and spend there
um and so if you want to delete who
would own the store though where
you spent your v bucks yeah the the
company and so
so the company pays you and you pay them
the money but i'm gonna go figure this
out
yeah so we should set up wise town
by the way but uh you know like
obviously there's a million problems
with this people couldn't leave because
they had no savings except in their v
bucks
uh you know there was like i think
supreme
court cases about like free speech
rights and like that anyway they
went out of fashion because they were
horrible
um and they should have um but
you know the gilded age the the biggest
one of the biggest moments in sort of
wealth inequality in america at the end
of the 1800s
maybe maybe we're just back there now
you know like we're
it's like going back to the 80s and like
big hair is cool again
like just company towns are cool again
maybe coal mining
uh like i will say too just to
to do whatever we have a video coming
out soon that kind of talk
talks about some of the stuff that i'm
very excited about so you know
keep watching our videos i'm a company
man
this sounds horrifying um i
can't think of anything good that will
come of this i am would be interested in
the renewable energy town
but other than that i can't think of any
like benefit other than nevada's trying
to get
people to come to their state yeah but
like alex just pointed out like
looking at the history of company towns
didn't end well um in many cases
workers i mean this is like one of the
reasons why you know unions got formed
because people had to band together and
use their collective power
to be like we would like to be paid in
money please
and what eventually happened is a lot of
those companies just left when it wasn't
convenient to do that so
yeah not not the best yeah if anyone's
interested in like a parody of what this
world
looks like uh there's a book called snow
crash which was recommended by our
director michael luxembourg
uh where basically like everything's
like you have sovereignty
of like different corporations so
there's like a company that runs a
neighborhood and like you're the
you're a citizen of that and they have
like whatever
everything's a constant war the mafias
run like a company slash sovereign
government it's really funny
it's called snow crash by i think neil
stevenson uh check it out
nice um well yeah we'll leave that there
have fun dystopian dreams kids
um so obviously would love to hear your
thoughts on that
are you afraid of that do you plan to be
a coveted sneak and do you get down on
friday
um so as always you can write us and
call us call us
at 213-534-8807 that is 213-534-8807
you can write us at culture binge
wisecrack dot co no
m culture binge wisecrack dot co uh and
i just wanna say
thank you so much to everyone that wrote
in after last show
um in particular i was so psyched that
so many of you wrote in to talk about
corniness culture
um and i i we're not gonna go through
all those we can't
thank everyone by name but know that
those have all been read and i have like
stars on all those in my email inbox and
i want to keep thinking about this
corniness thing and
so many of you brought up interesting
ideas some of you made me feel good
about myself because you were like wow
mind lots of points there
but a few of you were like i don't know
about this big guy and i appreciate that
as well
um but thank you so much and i'm
planning in the coming weeks to talk
about that again
with with all of your work supporting me
i won't give you credit i'll take credit
for it
um but truly appreciate that and like
always keep writing keep calling
um so we'll go let's look at what we got
this week alec what have you
curated for us yeah uh we've got a
voicemail from bongo
on cornyn's culture hey this is bongo
coming from spokane washington
for the most recent culture binge
episode i was listening to
the discussion y'all were having on
corniness and the culture and i think
y'all
really were spot on in a way that uh i
personally have felt that but i've
probably not been able to
articulate and just give you some of the
examples you specifically
cited you know for example he meant a
gorman poem i
i honestly i couldn't listen to it i
just thought it was the cringiest thing
in the world
and you know i don't i don't have any
issue with her personally she
seems very nice that i didn't care for
it or even like what's the west wing
uh we used to play it every friday in my
eight week of class in high school
and i was like one of the only students
that just thought it sucked
um i just got roasted endlessly
for it because everyone else loved it i
just hated it and hated when it came
along so i'd rather just
learn what we were doing than interested
in the subject
but uh yeah you know i thought that was
really interesting discussion
i love the show and sorry actually this
looks like a three-minute
voicemail uh because i recorded it and i
messed it up and i tried to delete it
but
anyway enjoy the show bongo it's okay we
all try our best
um also bangalore is that your
government name or a nickname by the way
it rules
um but thanks for that and that his his
example of
uh you know a government ap government
ever playing the west wing is exactly
what i'm talking about
that the infection of corneus culture
and the idea that watching an aaron
sorkin show is going to teach us about
like the glory of government
come on yeah you're that teacher i
really don't fire them i mean i don't
mean to minimize other awful things but
i think
aaron sorkin has done more to her
popular politics than
many other things that have happened in
the last 20 years yeah he's worse than
mussolini i'll say
just kidding kidding uh we got we got
some emails uh
culture binge at wisecrack.co if you
guys want to send us a line uh just a
quick one from max
about the game stop a story we talked
about a while ago
uh just a fun little ant in australia
there's a mining company that has the
same ticker code gme
and their stock shot up and it's
really funny so thank you max for
sending us that uh we got an email
from oh there's a really good one that i
love so much
uh it's very uh i'm interested in things
that
uh categorize things very extensively
and yeah this email is so good yeah yeah
on on corny's culture there's an email
from lars lars thank you so much uh i
want to show you guys specifically
michael a list i've made related to the
discussion on coordinates in our culture
i intended this list to categorize how
we like or dislike things in this
culture here it is so this is an
exhaustive list
of the different ways you can relate to
liking or disliking things
all right so just gonna go by pretty
fast likes dislikes the thing
normal dislikes the thing because others
like the thing
hipster contrarian likes the thing
because others dislike the thing
edgy contrarian likes the thing
ironically
ironic likes the thing ironically for so
long that it doubles back and becomes
unironic meta ironic likes the thing
before others likes
the thing and boast about it hipster
dislike the thing but only likes the
thing now because other people started
to like the thing
bandwagoner didn't like the thing but
now likes thing because taste change
normal likes the thing and takes upon
themselves to deem it if others truly
like the thing and can be
in the liking thing community based on
standards made up in their head that's a
gatekeeper
genuinely likes the thing and doesn't
care if others dislike the thing because
they understand everyone has their own
taste preferences
that's normal genuinely dislikes the
thing and doesn't understand
uh oh sorry there's two normal generally
dislikes the thing and doesn't
understand why others
like the thing but doesn't boast about
it also normal does not necessarily like
or dislike the thing also normal
likes the thing obsessively fnatic or
stan dislikes the thing obsessively
cynic
likes the thing and thinks they're
better than others because of it elitist
smarter than others because of an
intellectual
trademark uh lars this is great i i feel
like it's a
not exhaustive list i think i think this
needs more work
and that's not that's not uh dunking on
you because i think this is an amazing
start and i just need to know all the
various ways that people categorize
of how you could like things so thank
you yes amazing lars thank you so much i
i like yelped with joy when i opened
that email yeah
i think there needs to be like likes a
thing because it
uh likes likes the thing because they
like the the political messaging of it
aligns with their own political values
even though the thing itself is
fine or whatever yeah or like likes the
thing because your friend's mom likes it
and while you wouldn't say you're
attracted to her she fills this void
left by your own mother so by affirming
your friend's mom you feel like you
can access a love you never had yeah or
like
likes the thing because you need to in
order to survive in your company culture
something yeah like or like likes a
thing because someone with a mask has a
gun to your head and says if you don't
like it
they'll kill you yeah or
likes to think but sorry what no no
sorry
i'm just kidding we should not keep
going with these uh any more emails for
this time
uh yeah um we got a few ones about
corniness uh
let's go with
here's one from daniel uh daniel here
emailing again with some thoughts on
corny culture detailed explanations
below but my theory is that some of what
you're seeing is a response to two
different forces
one vastly different experiences
understanding expertise between
the uh between the all of the audience
that are engaging with the
at the same time same way and two binary
labeling of media content culture is
either good or bad
through social media sound bites versus
nuanced discussion
uh so this is number one some of the
corny don't
touch icons are very popular and are
given to a very wide audience of which
experts those involved the culture as
well as those
sorry this email i i think the grammar
is a little weird but i think i can
summarize
basically point one and i think it's a
very good point danielle
is that um things are why
are bringing stuff to a wide audience
like hamilton a lot of people not
interested in musical theater
get into hamilton and like this is cool
i like this whatever but then people
with a more of a background and say like
history or musical theater like
this isn't that good and they're like
how dare you dislike the thing that i
have
um same thing with amanda gorman like
you know not a lot of people are exposed
to a ton of poetry outside of maybe
middle school and sometimes high school
and so like it's fine and then
everyone's on the internet commenting at
the same time
uh about whether or not you have to like
this amanda gorman poem or you have to
like hamilton
um the other thing that daniel gets into
is that you know this is sort of touches
on
social media culture where it's not like
oh hamilton is a
enjoyable musical but you know some of
the history is
kind of wonky and there's there's lots
of decisions made and we can criticize
some of those decisions and not
necessarily call the whole thing bad or
you know say it's amazingly good uh but
social media does encourage that it
either has to be good or
basically uh canceled um and so i think
just you know the inability to think
about things in a nuanced way
and so i thought it was really good
points daniel absolutely
just i'm never not impressed by the
awesome people that
hang out with us on this podcast and
write in and contribute to the
conversations
um we should probably start wrapping up
unless you have another email you wanted
to get hit real quick
uh i think we can stop there
we got a lot of good ones but uh i think
yeah yeah if ever there was a week oh we
have so many good ones that we wish we
could get into
uh we don't have time to keep writing
them we'll get to this stuff so once
again culture
wisecrack dot 213-534-8807
and another reminder we talked about it
before if you want to interact with us
jump on hi-ho hi ho dot video slash beta
wisecrack and just a reminder the beta
is for ios
only right now so sadly we are going to
preference apple users
um but it will be uh open to everyone at
some point
so why not leave us the video voicemail
there
um so along with our email and our phone
number you can jump on hiaho
leave a message for culture binge there
respond to our story
um and we could include that as well and
with that too even if we don't get it on
the show
we'll just respond to you live on ohio
so you win we win everyone wins
say hi to hi-ho that's not their slogan
but if they want to use it
i'm i'm taking offers okay so uh real
quick before we end up
before we end up before we end where can
people bug you that's not
um at your house or on hi-ho
siripatel22 on twitter
great alec how about you i'm at
wisecrack alec
great at michael o burns um bug
us talk to us simp us but in a
respectful and not a creepy way
uh we'll be back in two weeks actually
alex just implied he wants to be sent in
a creepy way the
others of us we want respectful
something um so we'll be back in two
weeks streaming
we want to see you then jump on high ho
in the meantime that's all for this
culture binge bye
bye
you